2012 2013 se sont énormément de jeux et
de gros titres qui sont attendus comme
par exemple à leucate gta 5 ou encore
assassin's creed 3 nous avons désormais
voir les 15e et plus attendus de cette
année
go
[Musique]
premièrement sleeping dogs qui est sorti
le 17 août dernier un gta like assez
sympathique dans lequel vous incarnerez
oui chang un flic infiltré dans un
réseau de malfrats à hong kong démission
du côté flic ainsi que du côté malfrats
se présenteront à vous et vous devrez
user de vos talents afin de tout les
réussir son battre s'acheter des
serrures pirater les caméras vous battre
vous battre et vous battre
[Musique]
dans les jeux et plus attendus de cette
année on retrouve bien évidemment crysis
3 le fps futuriste aussi connu kahlo
développé par sir texture aux treizistes
le premier du nom était sorti en
novembre 2007 et avait su s'imposer par
ses graphismes simplement spectaculaire
et son gameplay futuriste très
accrocheur mais quelle surprise nous
réserve dans crysis 3 ils seront le 28
février prochain
avec un trailer aussi bavent que
d'habitude ubisoft nous assure la sortie
d'une suite
assassin's creed iii nouvel opus de la
série sorti en 2007 cette fois il ne
s'agit pas d'une suite de la trilogie
consacrée à edu auditor mais bel et bien
d'une nouvelle histoire de quoi nous
captiver de voir nos écrans durant de
longues heures on retrouve désormais
borderlands 2 la suite tant attendue du
premier du nom sorti en octobre 2009
dans des relances avait conquis son
public grâce à ses graphismes en cell
shading très prenant mais aussi grâce à
son aspect rpg qui faisait très bon
mélange avec fps du genre bordeaux lens
2 sortira le 21 septembre prochain
et honnêtement relatant impatiemment
parce qu'il a l'air de deux chiens sa
mère
[Musique]
medal of honor warfighter qui sortira le
25 octobre prochain est lui aussi
attendu par pas mal de joueurs beaucoup
sont pessimistes en repensant medal of
honor de l'année dernière qui a plus
servi ce brouillon et d'expérience pour
sortir un bac + 3 tout simplement énorme
on verra bien ce qu'il en est de celui
ci qui en tout cas équipée du moteur
graphique frostbite 2 le célèbre jeu de
ballon fifa est lui aussi très attendu
pour son 13ème opus qui sortira le 27
septembre prochain
au programme le réalisme sera encore
plus présente dans fifa 12 que ce soit
au niveau des collisions de
l'intelligence artificielle mais aussi
des gestes techniques et pour les fous
fous on aura de quoi encore s'amuser en
tirant des gros mots la horde durée
joueurs
[Applaudissements]
m
le tant attendu gta 5 figurent aussi sur
la liste des 15 jeux les plus attendus
de l'année
très peu d'imagés ont été divulgués
d'ailleurs on a juste vu l'apparition de
ce trailer plus depuis on n'a plus de
nouvelles
la sortie du jeu est prévue pour le 1er
janvier prochain j'espère au moins
mais ces dames on pourra encore écrasé
les mamies tu te manger un hamburger
masturber
splinter cell la clis le sixième opus de
la série qui nous présentera cinq
fischer donc le héros du jeu qui enquête
sur une opération terroriste la black
list au rendez-vous de l'infiltration et
discrétion de l'utilisation de gadgets
très évolués et le nombreux systèmes
killing in motion qui me permettra de
marquer vos ennemis avant d'effectuer un
combo juste magnifique les tuant tous un
parent
très prometteur ce splinter cell le tant
attendu il s'agit en fait du premier
titre d'une nouvelle trilogie mettant
ses master chief accompagné de cortana
alors halo 4 se passe en fait cinq ans
avant halo 3 qui est quand même assez
étonnant
à en juger par les images le jeu a tout
simplement l'air énorme et moi je dis
que c'est bis mode 3 kim est content le
jeu sortira le 6 novembre prochain et
qui expédie les dizaines d'hommes le
foot u need for speed initialement sorti
en 2005 qui va refaire son apparition
avec de légères retouches à comme
notamment l'ajout de frostbite 2 qui je
pense est quelques peu mieux que le
moteur graphique dès 2005 donc pas comme
ça on va terroriser les flics avec une
superbe voiture on pourra personnaliser
puisque faut rappeler que c'est quand
même ça à la base du parti d'un
personnaliser sa future voiture et on
affrontera tout comme en 2005 les
vilains de la fameuse liste noire
honnêtement je la torah pas seulement
carnet for speed most wanted c'était
pour moi le meilleur
aimanté pas on n'y a tout joué que ce
soit sur ps2
là j'ai sortira le 30 octobre prochain
ubisoft nous a fait la surprise de wadji
dogs un jeu d'action à la troisième
personne
donc en fait le joueur incarne un groupe
de hackers capables d'interférer avec
tous les systèmes électroniques qui sont
à la base sous contrôle de sociétés
privées
j'avoue que je me suis pas forcément
intéressés je mets en voir les images
c'est quand même intrigant puis ça a
l'air sympa et ça sort le 30 juin
prochain
voici maintenant le jeu qui me fera
acheter une foutue ps3 uniquement pour
avoir le plaisir d'y jouer
god of war ascension le célèbre beat
them all est de retour dans un quatrième
opus
on y retrouvera ares une sorte de
nouveau kratos qui cherchera à se venger
de la mort de sa famille on attend
impatiemment pour se défouler et ça sort
le 12 mars prochain une sortie très
original de cette année le nouveau tomb
raider on incarnera forcément lara âgé
de 21 ans qui d'ailleurs ont fait un peu
plus 15 à voir les images du jeu
développeurs pédophiles
je tiens à le dire non j'rigole donc on
se retrouve sur une île à la suite d'un
naufrage sur lequel il va falloir
survivre et qui dit survie dit chassez
médias aussi faire attention aux autres
pochtron qui rôdent sur l'île et qui ne
sont pas très cool
je vaux
définition
far cry 3 a prévu pour le 29 novembre
prochain fait aussi parler de lui vous
incarnez jason brody un homme qui se
retrouve perdu sur une île ravagée par
une guerre civile tu sais pas comment
mais tu es là au milieu de tout ça vous
allez devoir utiliser toutes sortes de
cali pour écouter ceux qui nous veulent
du mal comme par exemple lui qui j'avoue
c'est quand même un peu peur je veux
voir ma [ __ ]
on va pouvoir s'amuser des 29 novembre
prochain
et enfin même si j'ai mal compter que
c'est le 16e jeu et non 15e d'ailleurs
j'ai le sommes on attend la sortie de
black ops de cette fois ça se passe
plutôt longtemps après black ops premier
du nom les technologies sont bien plus
évolué et on va assister à une véritable
guerre du futur
le retour du mode zombie nous fait
plaisir à tous et à tout parce que ça
sent les nuits blanches à essayer lutter
contre ces zombies nazis a déconné entre
potes sur skype est aussi le mode multi
qui nous intrigue quand même tout c'est
tout pas mal une fois la boîte ça sort
le 13 novembre prochain et franchement
on va bien rire
le top 15 des jeux les plus attendus de
l'année c'est déjà fini
si vous avez des questions des choses à
dire n'hésitez pas à les poster en
commentaire
j'espère au moins que ça vous aura plu
car savoir a quand même demandé 20
heures de boulot c'est pas rien mais
sincèrement c'est vraiment plaisant et
j'ai adoré faire subtilité on se
retrouve pourquoi pas l'année prochaine
pour un nouveau top 15 est surpris très
bientôt pour des vidéos prix créé très
très fun vous inquiétez pas pour ça
et n'oubliez pas d'aimer la vidéo si ça
vous a plu bis
[Musique]
ah ah
zhu clément florent la couleur et nous
fils